okay my roommate actually hasn't
left the the house the entire day and i
have like five minutes to get this done
so i'm gonna go ahead and do it oh boy
oh boy oh boy
okay bitcoin what is it basically
bitcoin is a decentralized currency that
is basically built around blockchain
technology and as a result of not being
able to trust all of the parties that
are going to be running kind of the the
bitcoin blockchain on their local
computers we have to make a bunch of
adjustments to you know a typical
ordered log algorithm that we might see
in something like uh distributed
consensus like raft or paxos in order to
kind of make this all work out so let's
go ahead and quickly talk about some of
the features that bitcoin sports how
blockchain works and basically how that
is going to allow us to kind of make
payments in an environment where not
everyone trusts one another
okay so what are coins coins are
basically just a chain of transaction
records and they don't all have to
necessarily be stored next to one
another in the
in the actual blockchain itself but they
do have to basically create this chain
of records that shows who basically
holds a coin at a given time so imagine
i have some coin and this is going to be
indicated by the fact that um you know
as you can see in this first transaction
record here
my public key is at the top of it i have
the hash of the previous block that
basically gave me that coin and then i
have the previous owner's signature
which is basically using the the private
key to go ahead and encode the hash of
the previous block
so then imagine i do a typical purchase
that you know i might end up doing and i
give that coin to an only fans girl
basically what i'm now going to do is um
there's going to be a second transaction
record that i personally am going to
create and what's going to happen is now
there's this hash of the previous block
where the previous block is referencing
when i actually got the coin and i am
going to create a signature where i use
my private key and i've discussed
private and public keys in the previous
video on this channel i use my private
key to go ahead and encrypt basically
the hash of the previous block and that
way if anyone wants to go ahead and
verify that this payment is valid they
can go ahead and use my public key from
basically the referenced previous block
to go ahead and decrypt the signature of
this transaction and assuming it all
comes out okay it should show the hash
of the previous block and then you know
it was actually me who went ahead and
created this transaction record because
i'm the only one who should have my
private key
okay so basically even though you know
coins go ahead and create this record of
where um you know a coin has been held
throughout its kind of entire existence
it doesn't actually block double
spending you know for example there's
nothing stopping me from creating two
transaction records that spend that coin
twice so basically this is kind of where
the blockchain comes in we have to
basically go ahead and create an
ordering of events that everyone can see
so we know that once i've spent that
coin once i no longer have the coin and
then anytime i try to create another
transaction spends it again it can be
rejected because we know it's not
actually a valid transaction
so like i mentioned this basically
corresponds to this blockchain where a
blockchain is a set of blocks or more so
like a linked list of blocks which acts
as a record of all the transactions for
every single coin and each block
contains basically the following
again a hash of the previous block in
the chain
some transactions that are actually
going to be kind of in the block and
once that block gets put in the
blockchain those transactions are
considered valid and then also this
third thing called a nuns which i'll
explain a little bit more but it's kind
of used to prove the validity of the
block and show that this block is
actually valid to go in the blockchain
so every single node in the network
which can also be called appear keeps
this local copy of a blockchain and
every single time it goes and tries to
add a block it needs to go ahead and
broadcast the block to every single
other node in the blockchain which can
go ahead and verify the validity of it
and then add it locally to their own
copies
since every single transaction is going
to be shown on the blockchain like i
mentioned before no one can actually
double spend
okay
so in order to actually go ahead and add
a block you have to do the following
a pier is going to receive a bunch of
transactions and throw them into this
block eventually the pier is going to
have to take the entire block and say i
want to add this to the block chain so
before it can actually do that it has to
calculate the nuts and the nuns is
calculated by doing some intensive cpu
calculations which in bitcoin is known
as proof of work so what is the cpu
intensive calculation basically we have
to find some value x such that the hash
of the list of transactions which you
know can basically be given a hash via a
merkle tree which i've mentioned in the
past you use the root of the merkle tree
the previous block hash and x starts
with n leading zeros and so basically
the only way to actually find this value
x is to go ahead and brute force this
and so
in addition to actually kind of adjust
the difficulty of how much brute forcing
needs to be done the blockchain can
actually adjust that parameter n
to make it more difficult to actually go
ahead and mine a block and this way
they're able to kind of keep the tr the
transaction rate of you know new blocks
being added to the blockchain relatively
constant so i believe in bitcoin it's
about one block every 10 minutes can be
mined
okay and then additionally once that
nuts is found the block can be broadcast
to other peers and it's really easy to
verify that block because well basically
you really just have to check that the
hash of the list of transactions the
previous block hash and that nonce go
ahead and start with and leading zeros
so like i mentioned that's kind of one
step of validation but there are others
too
so like i said the first step is just
going ahead and making sure the hash
starts with a bunch of leading zeros the
other thing is that the previous block
hash actually points to an existing
block in the chain and hopefully to you
know a block in the chain that's
actually at the end of the chain
and then more importantly that the
actual transactions in the block are
valid this is kind of what makes uh you
know blockchain work is that you go
through every single transaction you say
well does the owner that's spending this
coin actually still own the coin
according to the blocks currently in the
ledger and if they do then it's valid
otherwise you're going to go ahead and
reject that block because it has some
invalid transactions in there
okay and then additionally peers
basically will just go ahead and accept
a block to their blockchain by basically
adding it to their local copy of a
blockchain and start trying to mine new
blocks with this previously accepted
block being used as the the previous
hash of any new block that they might
mine so that way this kind of gets
integrated
however
even though based on what i've said so
far works for creating this kind of
linked list of blocks it's still
possible for there to be forks in the
blockchain there are two main scenarios
where this can happen
the first one is that two nodes in the
network which are called peers
may find the nuns of their own local you
know block that they're creating at the
same exact time and so nodes are going
to process them in different orders you
know if we have two blocks a and b that
are recently created some nodes may
think a comes before b other nodes may
think b comes before a and as a result
we're going to have this fork another
possibility is that one malicious peer
because they're trying to double spend
is going to send a block to a subset of
nodes and then a different block to
another subset of nodes and once it's
processed by
kind of both sets of nodes now you can
basically you know doubly spend a coin
which is going to be very bad but
there's a way for bitcoin to actually go
ahead and make sure that at least
eventually it's going to be the case
that you can only spend
coins one time
so the way they do that
is they resolve conflicts by keeping the
longest possible chain so basically
piers are going to have these forks and
um this is possible which is totally
fine however it's going to basically
keep working on the fork that it
received first
and the second that it sees another
branch of the fork has actually gotten
longer than the branch that it's been
working on it's going to go ahead and
abandon the branch that it's currently
working on and start creating new blocks
that are linked to the end of that
longer branch and this way
every single peer in the network is
eventually just going to make sure that
they're working on only the longer
branch and as a result of that they're
all going to eventually be consistent
during this time
double spending is technically possible
however the way that most bitcoin
clients actually work are that they wait
for a few blocks to actually go ahead
and be added to the end of a given block
so that they know that it's very likely
that this transaction is actually valid
because most kind of invalid blocks that
create a fork are going to be ditched
after a couple of iterations
okay
in conclusion bitcoin's really awesome
technology as is blockchain and
it's becoming very commonplace in our
society however it obviously has its
issues mainly surrounding both speed
which i touched upon and also proof of
work which is super wasteful of cpu
resources
so as a result a bunch of alternative
implementations it basically popped up
and they're starting to gain some ground
as well so i'm not really going to cover
those on this channel because it's not a
blockchain channel
but that being said it is something to
further research and it's actually
really cool to see how you know other
blockchains have gone about avoiding
this proof-of-work mechanism and used
more clever solutions to not waste cpu
resources and be a lot faster